to give a warm welcome to our
spokesperson on social protection
communities and Rural Affairs an amazing
west of Ireland women our youngest Shin
fentiri the deputy for Roscommon and
Galway Deputy Claire Curran
[Applause]
Accords
it is Grace to be here today with
activists who are enthusiastic for
change passionate about the future and
determined to build a new Ireland
make no mistake led by our next speaker
we will deliver for all of our people
[Applause]
akarja I am so proud to introduce the
leader of the biggest party on this
island the woman with the vision to
change Ireland for the better
the woman we hope will be our next fee
shock
edron hinfain Mary Lou McDonald
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
am I again
the reminders
[Applause]
thank you
thank you my friends we meet in Dublin
in a spirit of ambition
enthusiasm hope for the future
today we Seize the Day chart new
directions capture opportunities that
lie ahead A New Dawn is Breaking in
Ireland we stand on the threshold of a
new era friends it's time for change
[Applause]
so much so much has happened since last
we met things have been tough for so
many of you that join us tonight
struggling with an unbearable cost of
living
I want to acknowledge your resilience
under enormous pressure you're holding
the line holding it together for
yourselves your families your community
this crisis won't last forever
but you deserve the political leadership
to support you through these difficult
times and to match your hopes for the
future that's the job of good government
we are ambitious for change those
Ambitions aren't confined to Ireland
we send solidarity to people who endure
imperialism War occupation and the
denial of Human Rights we send our
unwavering support to Palestine
Ukraine fights for its very survival
against Putin's criminal Invasion we
stand with Ukraine
and
until that day when your beloved
Homeland is free from Russia's War
Russia's war must end and the journey to
peace must start now
Ireland stands on the side of
international law against those who
trample on the rights of others be it
Putin's war or Israeli apartheid
though our world has changed our values
remain strong in hard times when the
odds are stacked against us when hearts
are heavy with loss we come together
in Donegal following the tragedy of
Chrysler families face the Heartbreak of
the empty chair
we can only imagine the enormousy of
your loss but know that you are not
alone the nation wraps its arms around
you
the outpouring of sympathy for Chrysler
stretched far beyond our Shores and acts
of solidarity and condolence from the
Irish abroad
in this moment of profound grief we saw
again that to be Irish is not just to be
from a small island but to be part of a
very large Global family who have built
their lives in Britain the United States
Canada Australia and Beyond we are so
very proud of them they have kept Faith
with home
[Applause]
to our young people
who once again depart our Shores you've
been very badly let down especially by
the Broken
housing system
I want you to know that we are working
hard to change things for you we'll make
Ireland the home that you deserve
so as you travel enjoy your experience
work hard play hard but come home and be
part of the new island that we must
build we need you
[Applause]
foreign
for change is strong and growing with
the energy of the generation impatient
to claim their future to achieve a new
Ireland
100 years ago Ireland was traumatized by
partition divided by bitter Civil War a
century on WE strive for a nation that
honors and learns from its past but
isn't held back by it
this spirit for change was so powerfully
expressed in May's Assembly Election
Shin Fein emerged as the largest party
and for the first time a republican a
nationalist a woman from Tyrone was
elected as first minister in
a space
elected in a state designed to ensure
that there could never ever happen with
friends it did Michelle O'Neill a first
Minister for all
[Applause]
and there's no turning back
there is now no job in the land of
limits to anyone the days of
second-class citizenship are over a new
generation moves together
moves together to a New Ireland where
everyone has the chance to realize their
dreams to push the boundaries to exceed
expectations to succeed to change
Ireland
change Means A Place Called Home a
secure affordable roof over your head it
means access to a doctor to hospital and
to care when you need it it means real
opportunity good jobs decent pay and the
right to retire at 65 on a fair pension
foreign
change means taking those final steps to
full nationhood ending partition
reunifying Ireland
[Applause]
Horizon change is now on our doorstep it
can't be stopped by the dup who refused
to accept the result of an election and
prevents the formation of an executive
while they left workers families
businesses without support ministers
like Connor Murphy stepped up
[Applause]
and the people of the north the people
of the north deserve needs demand a
government that works for them this
stalemate can't continue British
government dithering must end they must
immediately bring Clarity a timetable
for concluding negotiations with the
European Union and the restoration of
the executive
but whatever happens
be clear that direct rule from London is
not an option
working together working together is the
only way forward
change can't be stopped by Fiona fall
and finagale now so joint at the hip
that it doesn't matter to them which
leader is they shook so long as it's one
of them
[Applause]
so
Leo leaves me whole goes in mijo leaves
next month leeho goes back in in out in
out political Hokey Pokey
that's the Cozy Club my friends that has
ruined this state for a century well fan
of fall and Finnegan have had their time
they've had their chance it's time for a
new government a government of change a
government for the people
[Applause]
foreign
can't be stopped by the chaotic Tories
in London either I mean they can't run
their own country without bringing it to
the brink of financial ruin
they they certainly have no right to
tell the people of Ireland how to run
ours
[Applause]
they attacked the Good Friday agreement
an agreement that's delivered 25 years
of Peace a peace consistently defended
by our partners in Europe the United
States and Beyond
they disgracefully seek amnesty for
their troops and deny victims of the
conflict Justice
they attacked the protocol an agreement
that protects livelihoods and our
economy they care so very very little
about Ireland well the Tories can leave
governing of this island to the people
who live here and we will shape a better
future together
thank you
that better future calls to us asking
the big questions of us and I believe
that this generation has the answers
This is Our Moment Ireland has three big
opportunities in this decade the
reunification of our country the
achievement of energy Independence and
the power of our young people brimming
with Talent ideas and energy
yet those in their 20s and 30s will
likely be the first generation worse off
than their parents that's not right we
must renew the promise that if you work
hard you can get ahead and build a good
life
this generation looks with fresh eyes
and fresh Hearts to the Ireland that can
be they know Ireland's success must be
driven by inclusion and equality that
there's a seat at the table for everyone
for our traveler Community our ethnic
communities our citizens with
disabilities our lgbtq plus citizens and
no words of hate from any pulpus or any
stage will set us back or divide this
generation
foreign
people refuse the boundaries of
yesterday they reach for opportunity for
their shot for their chance and if we
give them that chance our young people
will transform Ireland
so the question for the rest of us is
straight and simple are we prepared to
do the work with them and the answer
must be yes yes and yes again
[Applause]
foreign
people will change housing locked out of
affordable homes locked into
extortionate rent living in a society
where children grow up in hotel rooms
Government after government has failed
on housing that's the truth Target set
targets missed deadlines set deadlines
missed big on promises short on delivery
well young people are calling this out
and we will work with them to deliver
the biggest affordable and social
housing program that Ireland has ever
seen
our young people will change Healthcare
we saw during covid-19 how student
nurses and midwives put everything on
the line
those who have kept our health services
together for decades taught them well
they demonstrated the skill and
compassion innate in all of those who
work in Health Services across Ireland
this generation has no time for
inequality in health care refuse to
accept hard excuses that leave more than
one and a half million people on waiting
lists or the jaded Alibis that give
people and leave people on Hospital
trolleys they know overcrowded two-tier
Health Systems do not work that a border
in health care does not work we need a
fair Health Service we need a National
Health Service for all of Ireland
we now have
we now have
octoilga we now have Australian
oh compassion to free nails
the spirit and China culture gonchanga
tear gone Adam is
[Music]
we now approach
we now approach
our first normal Christmas for three
years the time of great excitement and
yes there is attention and uncertainty
as the bills Stack Up government has
been far too slow to respond
long before Russia invaded Ukraine
living costs were out of control you
felt it in your pocket every day
government had to be forced into action
by the opposition and by public pressure
forced to curb soaring fuel gas and
electricity prices
forced to introduce a winter eviction
ban forced to provide relief for renters
now they dragged their heels as mortgage
holders are walloped with interest hikes
just like they dragged their heels on
ripoff Insurance course while rest
assured piercedarity will not let this
drop
thank you
you shouldn't have to force your
government to protect you
governments should be open asses on your
side we need that government with ideas
that can plan that can deliver
a strong and vibrant economy is core to
our vision for Ireland we will support
Innovation new ideas and new businesses
to succeed a strong economy needs
certainty affordable housing good Public
Services modern infrastructure and
energy security the energy crisis makes
one thing very clear our Island must
achieve energy security and energy
Independence we can achieve this by
harnessing our abundant renewable
resources building on our capacity in
Wind solar and green hydrogen and the
state must make Ireland's energy
Revolution a priority energy
Independence will be a game changer for
Ireland Transforming Our economy
creating new jobs opportunity Prosperity
Central in turning the tide of climate
change and achieving a just transition
so we need action
we need to plan and we need Pace we must
sort out delays in our planning system
we must invest in our Port so we can
pursue offshore energy work in
collaboration with business semi-states
and international Partners to realize
investment opportunities this moment
cannot be wasted
according to
we live in the end days of partition
on the cusp of an historic opportunity
the reunification of our country and our
people shaping a future for everyone
moving forward in the belief that there
is no them there's only us
us that call Ireland home we can build a
nation home for all our people
some are apprehensive about Irish Unity
I want you to know that in a new island
you will be cherished
included respected as equal citizens
this is your place
this is your home be part of shaping its
future
[Applause]
others others when others say yes to
Unity but not now
they're wrong
the time to plan for peaceful Democratic
constitutional change is now the days of
treading water are over
the Irish government must immediately
establish a Citizens assembly on unity
and if this government refuses to hear
tomorrow coming if it does not establish
a citizen's assembly Shin Fein in
government will
[Applause]
the future is ours for the making so we
need the right leadership with the right
ideas
Sinn Fein is ready to provide that
leadership
ready to lead government North and South
we have the team the policies the energy
to build that future we will get the
basics rights and the here and now and
drive ambitious plans for the future
to everyone watching tonight I'm asking
you to give us that chance to lead to
deliver for you your family your
community for all of Ireland
give us that chance that chance to lead
and we will get the work done
[Applause]
friends the Ireland we shape today is
our Legacy for future Generations
This is Our Moment
to write our chapter in our nation's
story
we Face challenges but this is a time of
Hope
and opportunity
so let's do big things
let's change Ireland
let's choose courage
ambition belief
let's be the generation that unites our
country and our people
let's build the nation home for all no
one left out
nobody left behind
our people are ready for change
and shin Fein is ready to lead
[Applause]
Ireland has seen some great days
but our gracious days lie ahead
days of unity
equality
Prosperity days that belong to everyone
friends that's a future worth believing
in worth working for worth achieving
I say we can do it
I say we must do it
[Applause]
my friends
Irish men and Irish women I say we will
do us
and we will do it together we will
change Ireland together unite Ireland
together is
all right
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]